[Musique]
intensification et multiplication des
conflits conditions climatiques
exigeantes le matériel militaire est
soumis à des preuves
quand il n'est pas engagé en opération
il sert à l'entraînement des troupes
[Musique]
sa longévité l'équipement la doit au
maintenancier de la défense
militaire ingénieur industriel ils sont
les artisans de ce qu'on appelle le
maintien en condition opérationnelle des
matériels un enjeu autant qu'un défi
de plus en plus nombreux les matériels
sont aussi de plus en plus sophistiqués
c'est le cas du Rafale
[Musique]
du véhicule blindé griffon
ou de la frégate multimisson qui
désormais largement passé à l'air du
numérique côtoient leur prédécesseur sur
le terrain et dans les ateliers
pour accompagner cette révolution
industrielle le ministère des armées a
repensé l'organisation du maintien en
conditions opérationnelles en s'appuyant
sur les nouvelles technologies
le budget alloué au maintien en
condition opérationnelles dans la loi de
programmation militaire
2019-2025 est significatif près de 35
milliards d'euros ainsi en 2020 ce sont
quatre milliards d'euros qui seront
consacrés puis en moyenne 4,5 milliards
d'euros par an d'ici 2023
le journal de la défense vous invite à
découvrir comment elle est maintenant
ciée des armées se sont adaptés à ce
nouvel environnement des opérations
[Musique]
c'est en 2017 que le ministère des
armées débute sa réforme du maintien en
conditions opérationnelles
priorité numéro 1 le domaine
aéronautique ou le constat est alarmant
la faible disponibilité des aéronefs
pèse sur les formations et
l'entraînement du personnel
[Musique]
en avril 2018 une direction de la
maintenance aéronautique est créée pour
faciliter la coordination entre
militaire et industriel
[Musique]
le contexte aujourd'hui est différent de
celui d'autres fois il y a beaucoup plus
d'opérations extérieures nous avons
besoin d'avoir une meilleure
disponibilité pour nos équipages l'ex
principal de la réforme du maintien
Russie opérationnel aéronautique c'est
de rénover notre relation avec
l'industrie et de créer un vrai
partenariat avec les industriels d'un
côté nous allons leur donner plus de
moyens pour s'organiser dans la durée et
en contrepartie nous leur demandons un
véritable engagement de performance pour
satisfaire nos besoins et le besoin de
nos opérationnels cette relation rénovée
doit permettre d'atteindre des
disponibilités bien supérieures à celle
que nous avons aujourd'hui bien
évidemment cela va prendre un petit peu
de temps puisqu'il faut le temps que les
choses s'organisent et que les moyens
soient mis en place
les progrès sont déjà au rendez-vous le
nombre d'heures de vols des Fennecs de
l'armée de terre est passée de près de
2500 à 3700 heures en Inde soit une
augmentation de près de 60% de leur
activité
dans le cas de la flotte rafale de
l'armée de l'air et de la Marine
nationale une large part de la
logistique a été confiée à l'industrie
de l'ingénierie à la distribution de
pièces dans les ateliers en passant par
le stockage et le transport
sur le plan technique nous avons mis en
place un plateau technique état
industrie ou des spécialistes
techniciens et ingénieurs de l'industrie
et de l'état travaillent ensemble pour
apporter des réponses à l'ensemble des
problématiques techniques qui sont
soulevées par les utilisateurs sur le
terrain alors la première spécificité du
Rafale et bien c'est son engagement le
Rafale est engagé en permanence sur des
contrats opérationnels que ce soit pour
la dissuasion nucléaire la police du
ciel ou les opérations extérieures
depuis les bases de l'armée de l'air ou
le porte-avion Charles de Gaulle il
était important pour nous de nous
assurer que les nouvelles prestations de
soutien que l'on met en place reste
compatible de ces modes de
fonctionnement opérationnels
particuliers la deuxième spécificité de
la flotte rafale c'est son ampleur la
flotte rafale c'est environ 150 avions
les deux tiers pour l'armée de l'air et
un tiers pour la Marine nationale pour
environ 35000 heures de vol par an
concrètement la flotte rafale c'est 700
000 équipements qui volent tous les
jours et qu'il faut suivre la flotte
rafale c'est plusieurs millions
d'équipements en stock à gérer c'est
plusieurs milliers de directives de
maintenance et plusieurs dizaines de
milliers de mouvements logistiques à
suivre tous les ans
jusqu'à présent l'entretien du Rafale
dépendait d'une vingtaine de contrats à
terme il devrait en rester moins de 5
majeurs
[Musique]
en parallèle des actions menées par la
direction de la maintenance aéronautique
chaque armée conduit ses propres actions
c'est le cas de l'armée de l'air
nous avons en enjeu complémentaire et
notamment avec le poids de plus en plus
pesant des opérations extérieures dans
la durée et dans l'intensité aussi nous
devons nous adapter et faire évoluer
nous aussi nos paradigmes j'ai décidé de
lancer un projet
appelé NSO 4.0 NSO pour niveau de
soutien opérationnel et 4.0 pour faire
une référence à la quatrième révolution
industrielle que nous vivons
actuellement
et de saisir toutes les opportunités
liées aux innovations et à toutes ces
grappes de technologies à notre
disposition
[Musique]
ce nouveau programme de maintenance
opérationnel a conduit à une
réorganisation des escadrons de soutien
technique aéronautique de l'armée de
l'air
[Musique]
c'est le cas de l'ESTA chalos qui
applique des méthodes de Lean Management
un travail collaboratif mené autour de
plusieurs projets comme la mise au
dernier standard du Rafale
on a industrialisé cette modification là
comme un industriel privé aurait pu le
faire de façon à être efficace et
performant dans le pilotage et dans la
réalisation de ce chantier et à ce titre
là on a travaillé sur l'ordonnancement
des tâches donc en intégrant des outils
informatiques modernes on a également
travaillé sur l'aménagement du poste de
travail avec des méthodes type 5S qu'on
va retrouver dans le lead management et
on a mis en place des indicateurs de
performance qui nous permettent de
suivre notre performance dans la
réalisation de ces chantiers de façon à
analyser et vraiment gagner en
performance et infiner t'acheter de
réduire le délai de modification des
avions là aussi les progrès n'ont pas
tardé cette nouvelle organisation a déjà
permis de diminuer de moitié le temps
nécessaire à la dépose et au remontage
d'un moteur d'avion A400M
la Direction générale de l'armement
expérimente aussi des solutions auprès
des armées
[Musique]
comme ce drone de maintenance 100%
automatisé né d'un partenariat entre Air
France industrie la start-up donecle et
l'armée de l'air
il doit venir remplacer l'inspection
visuelle par des techniciens nécessitant
le montage d'échafaudage ou
l'utilisation de nacelle
une alternative plus simple donc plus
rapide et plus sécurisée
testez ici sur la wax l'inspection par
drone pourrait à l'avenir se généraliser
sur tous les aéronefs
au sein de l'atelier industriel de
l'aéronautique de Clermont-Ferrand des
méthodes innovantes sont développées au
service de la maintenance
ce qu'on appelle des contrôles non
destructifs
la radiographie
le resuage qui consiste à appliquer un
liquide sur une matière pour en faire
ressortir les défauts
ou encore l'échographie par ultrason
ces techniques réalisables sur tous les
aéronefs permettent d'évaluer l'état de
santé d'une pièce de sa matière sans la
détruire
les techniciens utilisent des moyens
ultrasons qui ont été miniaturisés et
portatifs pour pouvoir être utilisé
simplement efficacement et rapidement en
OPEX donc là ils sont arrivés avec deux
manettes qui contient l'ensemble des
moyens ultra sans multi éléments et qui
vont permettre de contrôler
intégralement la voilure et de faire des
cartographies qui sont demandées par le
constructeur lors d'études de
vieillissement ou lors d'impact que l'on
peut trouver sur voilure ou sur les
entrées d'air ou sur tout élément
composite du Rafale
ce contrôle multi-éléments se Rafale est
une nouveauté pour l'armée de l'air
l'idée de contrôler le revêtement la
peau de cette voilure qui est quasiment
intégralement en carbone donc elle est
soumis à pas mal d'efforts pendant les
vols et
tous les certains cycles on est censé
vérifier l'intégrité structurelle voir
si le carbone s'est abîmé ou pas donc
pour cela on utilise la technique
d'ultrason ouais c'est un contrôle le
nom destructif un peu comme dans le
médical voilà c'est le même principe
c'est pareil échographie avec une petite
roue et là on vient cartographier la
zone avec plusieurs passes pour venir
scanner la matière
et par un principe de code de couleur on
arrive à visualiser l'épaisseur du
revêtement et tout ce qui peut être
susceptible d'être endommagé donc là on
peut distinguer sur cette zone un
contour de trappe ou un point d'emport
qui ressort ainsi bien à l'image et on a
un fond vert uniforme si on avait une
couleur vive qui apparaîtrait dans ce
fond vert uniforme on saurait qu'il y a
une dommage
place au diagnostic sur ordinateur
l'adjudant Anthony affiche une
cartographie de la zone examinée sur la
voilure de Rafale l'analyse peut révéler
des défauts invisibles à la une
le comptoir sur avion il nous paraissait
bon mais là en poussant un petit peu les
réglages en optimisant la palette de
couleurs on peut faire ressortir deux
zones critiques sur les extérieurs le
contour de plaque c'est là où les
efforts sont soumis par exemple lors
d'un serrage ou si c'est un emporte
c'est là où ça va travailler
avec la PS4 santé plus flagrant les
données récoltées sont ensuite traités
avec le constructeur de l'appareil ou
les ingénieurs de la Direction générale
de l'armement qui décideront de l'action
à mener puis archiver
123 jusqu'à
75 prochaine étape compiler ces données
pour chaque aéronef dans un carnet de
santé numérique un outil qui
faciliterait encore davantage le travail
du maintenancier
pour l'ensemble du soutien des forces un
autre défi à relever l'écart d'âge entre
les anciens et les nouveaux équipements
plus de 60 ans sépare l'avion
ravitailleur C135 et son successeur le
MRTT Phénix
la même chose pour la partie terrestre
[Musique]
l'année dernière le soutien est pris en
compte au plus tôt très en amont dans la
conception des matériels futurs c'est
déjà une première une première avancée
notable et qui pour nous va se traduire
avec les matériaux scorpions qui
arrivent et qui sont à la fois source de
progrès les sources de défi la totalité
de l'armée terre qui va être irriguée
par ses nouvelles technologies dont on
attend beaucoup en termes de performance
opérationnelle sur le terrain quand les
unités seront déployées
avec l'arrivée des nouveaux matériels du
programme de modernisation de l'armée de
terre scorpion il faudra bientôt
soutenir 4 générations de véhicules
différents
on va être soumis à une forte pression
sur la conservation des compétences qui
nous sont utiles pour continuer à
soutenir les matelas génération
tout en acquérant les compétences
nouvelles pour soutenir les matériels
Scorpion et ce pendant une phase de
transition d'après une dizaine d'années
la formation à la maintenance de ces
nouveaux véhicules a été confié aux
écoles militaires de Bourges
les Griffons dont les premiers
déploiements en opération extérieure
sont prévues en 2021 embarquent des
technologies modernes des calculateurs
capables de donner en temps réel l'état
mécanique du matériel son usure mais
aussi les besoins en carburant ou en
munitions
importante dans le véhicule et
qu'ensuite on va partager entre les
véhicules et puis dans la chaîne de
commandement c'est l'apport de l'info
valorisation et donc il va falloir des
gens pour exploiter ces données on
commence à évoquer les perspectives de
l'intelligence artificielle qu'on va
introduire dans nos systèmes pour que
finalement l'intelligence artificielle
fasse la synthèse des données et apporte
à celui qui décide une information
synthétique il va falloir des
réparateurs des mécaniciens pour réparer
il va falloir des approvisionneurs pour
amener les pièces de rechange de ces
nouvelles technologies il va falloir des
logisticiens pour transporter ça depuis
la France les dépôts vers les théâtres
d'opération l'école du matériel est
impliquée dans la formation de ces
futurs profils nous avons aussi la
mission de concevoir les nouveaux
supports pédagogiques qui vont permettre
de réaliser cette formation on parle de
nouvelles technologies donc nouveaux
outils pédagogiques bien sûr qui vont de
avec ce nouveau métier et puis scorpion
c'est aussi une révolution technologique
donc nous étudions aussi l'impact de ces
nouvelles technologies sur les nouveaux
métiers
dans un premier temps les formateurs
Griffons ont travaillé main dans la main
avec l'industrielle ils peuvent
maintenant dispenser leur enseignement
aux maintenancier des régiments bientôt
dotés de ces véhicules en même temps je
vois que mes deux mains de contact
quatre barres sont venus en contact à
disposition des outils pédagogiques
modernes comme cet écran tactile destiné
à faciliter l'apprentissage des
stagiaires
cette tablette tactile va vraiment
apporter un plus ça va également éviter
les allers-retours entre la salle de
cours et l'atelier on aura en fait la
salle de cours virtuelle au sein même de
l'atelier et on pourra faire un
comparatif véhicule planche 3D ou
planche schéma électrique chez votre
Matic en direct avec les stagiaires
[Musique]
Big Data réalité virtuelle l'armée de
terre explore de nombreuses innovations
mais s'il y en a une qui l'intéresse
tout particulièrement c'est l'impression
en trois dimensions
l'idée faire face à l'obsolescence de
pièces et s'affranchir à des délais
d'approvisionnement
un élément fabriqué directement dans les
ateliers c'est du temps gagné
la 13ème base de soutien du matériel
dispose des moyens nécessaires pour
expérimenter cette technologie trois
imprimantes 3D
mais aussi des logiciels de dessin des
outils de conception et de
rétroconception
ici on mène toutes sortes
d'expérimentations de la numérisation
d'une pièce dont on n'aurait pas les
plans
[Rires]
[Musique]
au contrôle de la résistance de
l'élément imprimé
[Musique]
résultat l'atelier regorge de prototypes
comme se redresseur de chargeur de fusil
d'assaut fanas dans les mécanismes ont
été fabriqués grâce aux imprimantes 3D
l'arrivée de ces nouvelles technologies
d'impression a permis au personnel de la
13ème base de soutien du matériel de
renforcer son niveau d'expertise
on a été formé justement par les
fournisseurs du matériel des imprimantes
du scanner on a dû te former aussi avec
les logiciels qui s'y associés parce
cela nous a permis d'élargir notre
specte de compétence diverger nos
connaissances et en même temps de
pouvoir porter des réponses à des
problématiques qu'on les maintenanciers
désormais
la fabrication additive a déjà fait ses
preuves
agao au Mali les imprimantes 3D
arrivaient en avril 2019 sont utilisés
quasiment non-stop elles impriment jour
et nuit non pas des éléments complexes
mais des pièces utiles
donc là on est sur un commutateur de B4
qui a été cassé donc on va le remplacer
par une pièce qui était imprimée à
l'instant là on est sur une pièce
parfaitement identique ce qui fait que
tout est adaptable il y a absolument
rien pour la mater
et donc la pièce est fonctionné
directement on arrive exactement la même
fonctionnalité de faire les origines
[Applaudissements]
l'adjudant Fabien reçoit beaucoup de
demandes notamment des médecins
il fabrique des pièces variées pour
faciliter leur travail au quotidien et
protéger leur matériel
on demande particulière des médecins des
commandos a été d'avoir des protections
pour ce type de bouteille qui s'emporte
avec eux dans leur sac donc pour ce type
de bouteille ce qui est des produits
c'était ce type de pièce donc qui va
nous permettre d'avoir une protection
extrêmement légère mais surtout très
très efficace
donc ça ne bouge pas et donc
ça fonctionne très bien
en pleine mer aussi l'innovation est de
mise dans le plan de modernisation du
maintien en conditions opérationnelles
navales la numérisation est l'un des
chantiers prioritaires
un défi à relever les bâtiments et qui
arrivent sont beaucoup plus modernes ils
ont des systèmes numériques et donc il
faut à la fois maîtriser cette
complexité ces nouveaux systèmes cette
automatisation à cette numérisation qui
arrive et c'est aussi une très bonne
opportunité pour nous pour être profit
des nouvelles techniques de maintenance
des techniques qui s'appuient sur les le
Big Data sur la maintenance prédictive
c'est une opportunité pour mieux
réaliser la maintenance et donc on
travaille sur cet axe sur cet axe de
progrès
à Brest la frégate multimissions
Aquitaine est au bassin pour l'un de ses
arrêts techniques majeurs une sorte de
contrôle technique de grande ampleur qui
dure trois mois et renouveler tous les
trois ans
qui était prévu sur GPC GMS
orchestré par le service de soutien de
la flotte et sur lequel se croisent les
maintenanciers du service logistique de
la marine naval Group et l'équipage du
navire
le premier des défis c'est de d'arriver
à réaliser l'ensemble des maintenances
préventives correctives
et toutes les évolutions techniques qui
sont planifiées durant les 13 semaines
d'arrêt technique qui correspond à un
arrêt technique très dense le deuxième
des défis c'est de réaliser en
maîtrisant les aléases techniques qu'on
pourrait rencontrer lors de la
réalisation des maintenances préventives
qui sont réalisées pour la première fois
sur une frame je pense aux grosses
maintenance préventives comme les 20000
heures de lindabre les visites à 10 ans
de la bassonnarre ou encore la visite à
7 ans du radar MFR
au bassin ou en mer le service
logistique de la marine réalise les
opérations de maintenance qui dépassent
le niveau de compétences des équipages
sans atteindre celui des industriels
on intervient beaucoup donc sur du
correctif on intervient beaucoup aussi
sur du préventif donc là actuellement en
terme de préventif on est sur la TM de
l'Aquitaine donc là on a un gros plan de
charge sur tout ce qui est préventif les
bateaux évoluent forcément les nouvelles
technologies car ils sont les frais mais
surtout les types de bâtiments la grosse
révolution pour nous c'est en termes de
planification au vu de tout le flux de
nouvelles
compétences fin j'ai envie de dire tout
ce qui est préventif il y a tellement
d'interventions à faire que en terme de
planification là c'est devenu
un nouveau challenge pour nous
pression les hélices en décembre 2018 le
premier arrêt technique digitalisé était
conduit par l'industriel sur l'Aquitaine
naval Group est en train de développer
un certain nombre d'innovations
technologiques dans le cas de
l'optimisation de maintenance se servir
des données qui sont déjà disponibles à
bord parce que les freins sont déjà des
bâtiments très numérisés avec un certain
nombre de données disponibles et
conséquentes sur cet arrêt technique
majeur nous mettons en place un certain
nombre de tablettes digitales qui
permettent aux opérateurs de réaliser
leur tâches de maintenance avec le
support de le support associé de pouvoir
enregistrer les données
issues de leur tâches de maintenance ce
qui a plusieurs vertus d'une part ça
fiabilise la qualité de la prestation ça
permet de standardiser cette prestation
quelle que soit le site d'applications
et ça permet aussi de capitaliser le Rex
de ces opérations
jusqu'à présent en matière de soutien
seul le principe de maintenance
préventive était appliquée l'usure d'un
équipement ne pouvait être anticipée et
donc planifié tout a changé avec le Big
Data et l'intelligence artificielle
grâce à des capteurs intelligents
embarqués calculer les probabilités de
panne des bateaux et désormais possible
aux côtés du constructeur et de ses
sous-traitants l'équipage du navire
participe aux activités de maintenance
sur une frégate le l'enjeu du MCO c'est
de répondre aux besoins d'une frégate
qui est de se déployer loin longtemps et
en conséquence d'être endurante à la mer
donc il faut une frégate qui soit
capable de durer longtemps sans avarie
pour poursuivre sa mission et en plus on
a des équipements multiples
particulièrement complexes et donc il
faut avoir les compétences pour
entretenir pour maintenir l'ensemble de
ce matériel
la numérisation et l'automatisation des
systèmes ont permis de réduire par deux
la taille de l'équipage et de le rendre
plus polyvalent
ça demande des compétences beaucoup plus
variées il faut être capable de prendre
en compte des systèmes informatiques
dans l'ensemble du bâtiment il faut
avoir des spécialistes également de la
cyberdéfense pour comprendre l'ensemble
des risques les appréhender et les
traiter donc la grande différence elle
est là c'est qu'on est plus simplement
dans des bâtiments des bâtiments où on
avait des mécaniciens des électriciens
on est dans un mélange où le mécanicien
doit aussi être un informaticien il faut
être capable de faire d'avoir des
personnes beaucoup plus polyvalentes et
avec un niveau de compréhension plus
élevé
si l'innovation est une chance bien
réelle elle est aussi très exigeante
pour les équipes les matériels
militaires modernes et les nouveaux
outils de maintenance ont amené des
process de travail plus performants
le début d'une tendance qui est appelé à
ce généraliser
[Applaudissements]